It's always very illuminating to go back in time and look at the thought pieces
from computer visionaries, and particular I want to draw your attention to this
memorandum that was done back in 1963 that talks about intergalactic computer
networks. I encourage you to do a web search and get this document and read it.
Here is another one this document talks about the first time
computers talk to one another. The first computer to computer communication back
in October 29th, 1969. Now this is considered the
first ever email that was written by Ray Tomlinson
from BBN Technologies back in 1971, and with all the junk mail that
is floating around, you might be wondering why
email was invented in the first place, but
it is a useful tool when it is not junk. This is a log book that was
maintained by professor Leonard Kleinrock of UCLA who is considered
one of the networking pioneers. And, this log book records
the first time there was a computer to computer communication. A call was made
from UCLA to Stanford Research Institute. Host to host communication recorded
on October 29th, 1969. And this is the first ever computer to computer
communication. Here is another interesting chart. This chart shows all the
computers in the world in one chart. March of 1977. This is your
entire internet on one chart back in 1977. And
the model of a computer system back in 1975 was, you had a mainframe
computer, which consisted of a CPU, memory, and I/O devices like a disk, and
you have cathode ray terminals through which users can connect to the CPU
and use the CPU in a time-shared manner. So this was the model of the computer.
Back in 1975. Note that I'm not showing any connection to any network here. The
reason I'm giving you this buildup with all the first in computer technology and
the model of the computer system, is because the seminal paper by Jerome Swalser
identifies terminologies, you and I know, as
current day issues. Examples include denial of service,
firewalls, sandboxing, objects, and so on.